bill ackman of Pershing Square is on the
phone with us bill I want to start with
you on the record let's just make it
clear
have you your firm or anyone you
currently or have previously employed
been contacted or subpoenaed by the
Justice Department or the FBI no not to
my knowledge not to your knowledge so
for example no I don't I have no no one
has Pershing Square has been contacted
by the FBI
what about consultants who you've worked
with like global strategies group evelyn
mantilla
my understanding is Global Strategy
Group has been contacted by either the
DOJ or the FBI I'm not sure which one
and some of their subcontractors have
received subpoenas and you have paid
global strategies group to do what
they're a government relations firm and
they consult on and help advise with
respect to you know dealing with the
government and you know state local
federal as well as lobbyists and you
paid them to help you with the Herbalife
campaigns that's correct
build beyond global strategies what
other consultants or other parties to
your knowledge have been contacted by
interviewed by or subpoenaed by the
federal law enforcement of prosecutorial
authorities I don't have no idea so
global strategies is the only one that
you're familiar with
I think it's global strategies and maybe
some people that they have subcontracted
I think you know if there are an
organization based in New York and then
they have sort of groups they work with
who do similar things in different
states and so if we're working with a
regulator in a certain state or a
government official or whatever we might
hire a local lobbying organization and
any my thing is that you know I don't
think it's the massive number but I
think it's a handful of people have
received you know the government is
asked to talk to then are you concerned
that you're the big fish so while you
haven't been subpoenaed yet and you have
not been told your target the fact that
the FBI or the DOJ has contacted
consultants or people who have worked
with you are you concerned
that you are the ultimate target who
they want to go after no not at all why
why do you think they would go after
them I don't actually think they're
going after anyone that's my guess is
you know look Herbalife is now under
investigation
it's the one year and my name one or two
day anniversary of the Federal Trade
Commission investigation it's two years
in a couple months for the SEC and it's
over a year since the DOJ launched an
investigation and according to press
reports of Herbalife and you know I've
been I've been here before
interesting the Herbalife worked with
the Joelle Frank firm and they fired
them sometime in December and they hired
Sarver Benin another firm and sard
represented em dia and they had very
similar kind of approach and their
approach was let's see if we can attack
the attacker and and and they've been
I'm sure lobbying the government's very
aggressively
you know questioning everything we're
doing and the government flee so if
assuming this is the press reports and
everything is true is looking in to make
sure that perjury square didn't do
anything illegal and you know if you if
you read the the story in the paper you
know story says that this is in
connection with market manipulation I
mean Herbalife has been accusing us of
market manipulation since the day before
we made our presentation Mike Michael
Johnson on TV and said that you know
there's been a market manipulator in
stock and now we know who it is they're
giving a presentation tomorrow market
manipulation is when someone
intentionally makes false and misleading
statements about a company for the
purpose of you know driving down the
stock or driving up the stock I have
made only truthful statements backed up
by enormous research all of our
materials are on two websites facts
about Herbalife comm and our pyramid
scheme comm we have we have every
presentation we've made we put up there
we have video recordings we have audio
recordings we have transcripts we have
all the documents that we use with
respect to our research there no one has
ever provided more transparency about
the work they've done the video that
you've shown I remember you showed a
video with us just maybe a month or two
ago maybe in January or December before
your puts expired that video that you
showed was any of it edited because
maybe could one make the argument if you
look at a four hour video what bill
actually pieces together
and puts in his presentation is you know
slice and dice to tell his story by the
way I really strongly encourage you to
watch the entire video which we put on
our website and we also put on kind of a
greatest hits collection of excerpts and
the excerpts accurately characterized
the whole video but the whole video was
there for people to to look at it we've
given that to the government that is a
three hour video that was done by
Herbalife of a private meeting of top
Herbalife distributors talking to other
distributors in the presence of senior
management of the company basically
explaining how they deceive people and
it's a remarkable it's a remarkable
document I'm going to interrupt you for
just a moment because I'll acknowledge I
have not watched the whole video I've
watched some of the excerpts that you've
made available but some of our
colleagues have watched the whole video
and they come away quite honestly with a
different impression that then you they
say and I'm paraphrasing here that the
video goes in to some of the kinds of
practices that Herbalife may have once
upon a time engaged in but ultimately
amounts to a an exhortation not to
engage in such practices in other words
people employed by directly or
indirectly by Herbalife or saying there
are some bad practices we may have done
them at one point in time but we
shouldn't be doing them well Herbalife
probably the reason why Herbalife
business is declining is because they
are starting to tighten up their
compliance regime the problem they have
is they can't operate legally and do
business and you know their distributors
are still out in the world misleading
people about the so-called Herbalife
business opportunity it's not just their
distributors you know in the last few
months that may be written address the
question about whether the video your
characterization of the video is either
a accurate or B what other people how
other proven characterize it the video
is as a document we put it out publicly
anyone can watch it and draw their own
conclusions we mischaracterized it and
no one has ever accused us of
mischaracterizing it and if you I
appreciate your drawing attention to
that video and I hope people watch it
but what I can tell you is herbal life
is a pyramid scheme they are harming
people by inducing them to sign up for a
business proposition where they're going
to lose their investments we know you
feel this way at this point this has
been an epic battle clearly you didn't
want to see this in the paper last night
today you don't want to have to defend
yourself on TV
want to shut this trade down your
investors have to be sick of it at this
point you had an amazing year last year
you don't need this garbage I'm sure I'm
sure investors are sick of it and and
you look you look at Whitney Tilson on
this Lumber Liquidators investment you
know this is a company that apparently
is causing harm by you know keep using
illegal wood that's cheaper and exposing
people to formaldehyde I think it's a
very very healthy thing for a short
seller to identify a company that's
defrauding consumers or harming control
Whitney Tilson has spent pennies
compared to the tens of millions of
dollars you've got a formal former
whistleblower who was going to be
involved in an ABC peace documentary
that you have to pay now you have to
backstop that guy that's a lot different
from Whitney Tilson situation the answer
is look we manage a lot more capital
than Whitney and you know when we are
when we spend money on a particular
investment whether it's a hostile
takeover or in this case a public short
we've sized the spending in the context
the size of the investment we spend a
few percentage points of capital here
and we think it's going to be a good
risk reward but by the way I've said
very publicly and our investors know
this as well if we think it's not a good
risk reward to be short over life we
will cover the reason why we think it's
a good risk reward to be short Herbalife
is we don't need the government to act
to make a lot of money here you know
pyramid schemes grow very quickly but
they so-called pop but they also drop
very quickly
Herbalife has missed earnings now for
the third time they took guidance got a
raise guidance in July of last year to
five dollars and seventy five cents I
think for 2015 they took that guidance
back in q4 and then they redid that
guidance just recently down to four
dollars and 20 cents I think they have
no idea how their business is going to
do over the course this year I expect
they're going to miss earnings yet again
you know over the course of this year so
I think it's a very good short just on
the business funded
and I do think however that the
government at some point here is going
to act and shut the business down I
think it will ultimately be a terminal
short we do we are short the stock for
economic reasons it is helpful however
when you're short a company and that it
is actually harming people because the
government here is motivated not to help
short sellers they're motivated to help
victims in the end the in the case of
you know I got again I make the analogy
to Lumber Liquidators you know we're by
exposing fraud you can help protect
consumers we're doing the same thing
here again we have an economic
motivation because we're investing
capital on behalf of our client i
speaking before you interrupt me
economic motivation we're working on
behalf of our investors and you know
fortunately there's also a good for
society benefit are for starting the
company down pardon me then bill i was
going to ask you what then about the
possibility that consultants you have
retained global strategies for example
may have made false statements to
regulators while employed by Pershing
Square what if that's the case and I
have no idea it again we have not
encouraged anyone to make false
statements and believe me you don't need
to make a false statement about
Herbalife to be negative about the
company you know we think the truth is
really what powerful here and the truth
is the company's harming people you know
I think we don't need to encourage
people or will exaggerate I mean what
more negative can you say about
Herbalife that it's apparent as a
criminal enterprise than harming people
what do prosecutors want to know what
kinds of questions have to your
knowledge what kinds of questions have
they asked a global strategies and
consultants and their employ under
subpoena I have no idea of what
questions have asked I have no idea what
answers were given I really have no idea
and I'm not sure it's my business to
know you know if you want to call its
government and ask them I encourage you
to do that but you know look I think
it's appropriate I have a lot of
confidence frankly in the Department of
Justice
you know we hired someone recently from
there I've had friends who've worked
there they are extremely capable lawyers
they know good from bad right from wrong
and look I think it's very important
that they make sure that the accuser
you know isn't making up stuff that when
we're explaining that a company is you
know harming people but I can tell you
like all I can't tell you that the
nature of the discussions we have very
proactively worked with the government
agencies here and assisting them in
understanding the company and we've had
many private meetings with other
government and conversations and shared
documents you know they don't tell us
you know when and whether they're going
to do anything with respect to Herbalife
but they seem appreciative to receive
the information and if they have any
questions for us they obviously know
where to find us and we'd be delighted
to answer any questions they have you
know we are registered investment
advisors we are audited on a regular
basis by the SEC they do look at our
trading and our emails and all those
kinds of things and if the government
had any problem with our activities I'm
sure they would let us know so you did
hire a former federal prosecutor Jenna
DAV's
and she's a former narcotics chief she's
never done anything in securities law
why does her skillset why does her
background suit you if it's not that
you're worried about an investigation
oh well Jenna it's terrific I've done
known Jenna since the MBIA days and you
might philosophy with respect to hiring
people is I hire very talented people I
mean while she spent her time and on
drugs and narcotics she also spent time
in her white-collar days working on
securities law and you know compliance
issues and things like that and those
are the principal areas that she's
focused on with us we are not concerned
about drug abuse at Burgess square bill
is there any potential connection
between this investigation into possible
stock manipulation and the departure a
couple of months ago of your former
chief legal counsel or Kassovitz
absolutely not Roy is terrific and he is
an outstanding guy and he's enjoying
life after working extremely hard over
eight or nine years here and I expect he
will be assisting one or more
presidential candidates getting elected
and that's his passion and he's done
very well economically at Pershing and
that has allowed him to take a break if
you know if you believe Herbalife is
behind this campaign they went out they
hired a high-priced fancy PR firm to
Punk this story out why do you think
Herbalife the
selves wouldn't have just sued you two
years ago for manipulation or slander
probably to be very clear George Sartre
personally called Reuters in January and
pitched this story were to spend a
couple of months looking into it
ultimately decided not to run the story
then sard pitched the New York Times New
York Times said that this was old news
and chose not to run the story and then
about 48 hours ago we heard from the
Wall Street Journal and you know we said
happy to answer any questions you have
you know whatever you need they
ultimately chose to run the story you
know so a win for a you know for a PR
firm
you know Herbalife wants us to us I said
before they're welcome to do that the
reason why they don't is we've gotten a
lot of information about Herbalife from
former employees who've shared
information with us and with the
government but we would not get the
motherlode we would if we had access to
you know if you accuse someone of being
a pyramid scheme they sue you saying
we're not a pyramid scheme well then we
have the right to actually have access
to their records to prove that they're a
pyramid scheme and that would put us in
a position as strong as the Federal
Trade Commission in terms of getting
access to documents and materials and
that's why they they don't do that I
just want to understand what you were
just saying the George sard whom
Stephanie and I know very well respected
PR executive pitched what exactly the
know said the allegation that stock
manipulation took place or something
factual based in fact that the US
Attorney's Office for the Southern
District here in Manhattan is
investigating potential stock
manipulation because there's a big
difference between the two my
understanding is that this story was
pitched by sard you know multiple times
I've heard this from the press directly
and he's what he's entitled to do that
and I'm you know clearly but you know I
again I'm as far as I understand the
government has contacted some employees
or subcontractors of global strategy
group I mean you know that and because
they're a firm that we hired that
becomes major news and the reason why I
am on your show is I'm happy to answer
any questions you have about anything
that we've done and and you know when
someone comes out with a story like that
and makes it sound like I'm personally
on
investigation I certainly want to
respond well we're not we're not
alleging that at all one iota yes what
we do want to understand is what
potentially this investigation may mean
for your position in her life the
interests of your investors to whom you
have a fiduciary responsibility the
answer is very little you know if the
government were to ask us for
information we provide it but the good
news is that market manipulations are
very very clear what market manipulation
is and that's when someone tries to
artificially move a stock price by
sharing false and misleading information
and that is clearly something that we
have not done here
you can you can argue you can argue can
I finish this sentence guys I'm really
look for small very few people in the
world and would come on to Bloomberg TV
after an article like that in the paper
so I'm doing this to be transparent and
to be helpful and I'm doing this for
reputational reasons but I can't I can't
finish the sentence it's hard it's hard
for me to be on be on your show so I'll
go ahead and ask your question and I'll
do my best
sorry bill I just wanted to get a better
understanding these letter-writing
campaigns these groups who you have
helped to have gone out for our
employees and complained I guess one of
the issues people are asking because
you've organized them all you've also
paid them so couldn't one make the
argument that you're sort of fueling
this no we've absolutely not paid any
former employees to go make public
statement absolutely not there have been
over a thousand Herbalife victims who
have filed complaints with regulators
over 300 in California many in New York
many in Illinois over the country we
have not be paid them nothing okay and
these are people who have been harmed by
the company and its really the
government's job to decide whether they
want to act you know look the FTC here
at an informal inquiry of Herbalife that
will actually begin we believe sometime
around the time the David Einhorn asked
his questions in May of 2012 and it
wasn't until March of 2014 that the FTC
launched a formal investigation which
requires a vote of a majority of the
commissioners at the FTC the FTC did you
know probably 18 months worth of work
they understood how controversial this
was this was a time when Carl Icahn and
all kinds of people were on the other
side very publicly promoting this thing
and despite all the noise the FTC looked
at the facts looked at the complaints
looked at the victims and launched a
formal investigation that investigation
has been underway for a year in two days
and we know it's a very intensive
investigation because if you look at
herbal eyes financial statements they
add back each quarter the expenses
they're spending on the FTC
investigation and just from March to the
end of last year they spent fifteen
million dollars four and a half million
in the fourth quarter alone you know
four hundred thousand dollars a week on
dealing with the Federal Trade
Commission so we know there's a very
intensive investigation by the Federal
Trade Commission our end we spend
nothing responding to subpoenas from you
know regulators with respect to our
activities in Herbalife you know if
regulators have any question about
anything that we've done we'd be
delighted to share information but I
think it's you know in market marks
manipulation is not something that we've
done and you know I encourage you to
talk to lawyers and ask them about it or
go to the SEC website it's based on
someone who makes intentionally false or
misleading statements clearly I've not
done that here bill at this point with
your trade structure the way it is what
is your break even on Herbalife I don't
know exactly but it's something in in
the range of the current market price
sorry would you mind repeating that we
shorted the stock around 47 or 48 but if
you add back all the various expenses my
guess is our breakeven is something in
the neighborhood of the current market
price about 36 bucks in other words well
mail them something in the mid-30s
do you believe then that you have
investors who want to say to you bill
enough is enough
let's just close this position down
remember Stephanie you and I had an
interview at the Robin Hood event yeah
and and remember the stock was at 73 and
you told me Bill shouldn't you be
closing this down you've lost a lot of
money isn't it time to move on we don't
make investment judgments frankly based
on what our investors think we don't
make investment judgments based on what
we think our investors want to do we
make invest in judgments based on a
entirely purely rational assessment of
risk and reward the opportunity for
profit and the potential for loss in the
case of Herbalife if you've been
following
what's going on with the business you
know watch I mean just just look at
what's going on with currencies right
Herbalife is going to be destroyed just
on currencies they produced the vast
majority of their product backed even
more today because they just opened a
factory in the u.s. to their costs are
in US dollars and they sell the product
in the following countries Venezuela
Brazil Mexico Russia and you know the
European Union right look at where the
euro is look at what it's done since the
biggest since January right you know so
when you've got US dollar costs and
you've got foreign revenues and the US
dollars appreciated 25 percent against
the euro what do you think is going to
happen to the company that's before you
consider the fact that they're having
difficulty recruiting new distributors
sorry what I'm saying is that the
business itself is collapsing right so
as the business declines when you're
short the stock you make money and also
the risk of being short obviously gets
reduced in the meantime the government's
been at it for a long time the FTC has
had you know over a year now of very
intensive investigations of the company
again that's judged by how much money
Herbalife is spending to respond to the
Federal Trade Commission it wouldn't
surprise me if in the relative short
term ie this calendar year
the FTC does something and we do not
believe that Herbalife can survive a if
they have to change their practices in a
way to make the business legal bill very
quickly before we go how much does it
cost purchasing square to keep this
position open much less than it did in
the past interestingly enough you know
the our short position there the company
no longer pays dividends and the cost of
borrow has stayed you know very modest
so that's not particularly expensive
options do have a clock associated with
them and we have paid to roll our
options you know when that that does
cost money but you know it's not a
particularly large position for us today
it's in the mid I think 5% of capital
you know part of that is that Herbalife
stock prices declined very significantly
and part of that is you know as you
mentioned Persians had a wonderful 2014
and a very strong 2015 and so you know
this is not a particularly large
position for us
you know every once in a while I have to
do a little bit of public relations so I
look forward to days like this obviously
I used to talk to Stephanie more so than
Eric but all right well we do have to go
to commercial because we have to pay our
bills here bill seriously thank you for
joining us we know you're right there's
not a lot of people who do put
themselves out there but Bill Ackman he
certainly does thank you so much for
joining us this morning bill bill ackman
he's a founder and CEO of Pershing
Square